here's number one very encouraging
yesterday
the the effort by some to downplay what
aaron rodgers said on sunday has failed
it has caught fire people are
recognizing that aaron rodgers
deliberately opened the door to
speculation about his future by saying
what he said at his post-game press
conference that's good
because if he's feeling that way and he
says it we can't go run and hide and
pretend it didn't happen
secondly now he may want other things
but one thing that i am though he wants
and deserves
is a little more of the green stuff
he's woefully underpaid in comparison to
the highest paid quarterbacks in the
game his cash for next year is in the
range of 23 million his annual per year
or his average per year excuse me is
33.5 million in new money that ties him
with jared goff which means either he's
locally underpaid or jared goff is
woefully overpaid or a lot a little bit
of both but he wants a new contract i
mean the guy's the best quarterback in
the game he's at 33 five mahomes is at
45 to sean watson to 39
and by giving him
number one more money number two more
security right more security i think
that's part of it as well you can do it
in a way that drops his cap number below
37 million which is currently what it's
going to be for 2021 chris so it all
makes sense it should want a new
contract well yeah it does make sense he
is underpaid goff is overpaid to your
point just to straighten that out and
then you know what
when did the uh all i'm like it's just
curious the thing i don't like is to
hear it this right now right i guess
you know when did this come out when who
when did this start getting talked about
did rogers put this on their radar yet
you know i i just i'm not in love that
this comes out now right the day after
you lose a football game it's not
necessarily the best look on aaron
rodgers i'll just say that well it's not
like he's banging on brian good's door
today what happens is he makes an
ominous statement about his future right
and people in the know
start trying to process it and people
who so i think it's kind of been there
how could it not be there as you are
tearing up the nfl right
and and you know what you're making and
you know what patrick mahomes is now
making what deshawn watson is now making
and you're the mvp you're the guy who's
tearing it up you're the guy who's
carrying your team without any help
around you to victories now desean
watson had no help around him but they
were four and 12 while he had a great
year
aaron rodgers had limited help around
him and they were 13-3 so i think it's
just part of what's there and also it's
important to remember when you give
someone a new contract with guarantees
and cap consequences you basically are
telling them you're here for two or
three more years and that's i think part
of what he's looking for yeah right
let's get some certainty and clarity on
what we want packers i think that's the
key are you going to give me
the clarity that i'm looking for or are
you not because if you're not then it's
a different conversation so i i think
that the problem gets solved quickly
yeah if they just if they just rip up
the contract and give him something that
makes it clear he's gonna be there for
two or three more years yeah that's
right that i think that just explains it
perfectly that's the bottom line right
it's about the security it's about the
knowing of like wait you're invested in
me which also means you're going to be
invested in the football team to support
me i hope all right and you're not going
to try to you know throw me off the
cliff or make me walk the plank for
jordan love two or three years from now
and you know everything's gonna be for
for for nothing you know so i understand
that i also understand i'm asking for
more money too right when you know
you're not gonna surrender surround them
with the tyree kills and the travis
kelsey's and the sami watkins of the
world okay then you know pay him the
difference i don't know what else to say
i mean
because it is crap at times with the
lack of support so yeah he needs this he
needs the financial support he needs
like the mental security from the team
to know that okay they're behind him
there's not some like alternative plan
going into the future about oh well hey
don't tell him you know we'll let him
play one more year but then after that
we're thinking about we got our own game
plan here and we'll do with him what we
want to do with him he's trying to get
the power in that situation and go no
you're not i'm i'm going to have to say
in that matter and you know hopefully
you'll have to pay me so much money and
a salary cap number will be so much to
where you know they're stuck with them
for a few years and they can't move on
and they are tied to him
another thing to remember about the
packers too because they don't have an
owner they're publicly traded and it's
not stock ownership like it normally is
it's a very strange situation that has
been around for years they had to raise
money to keep the team afloat back in
the 20s the nfl and people ask me this
all the time why don't other teams do it
because the nfl said no one else can do
it and it's not like you can go out and
buy up all the stock in the green bay
packers and have a
normal traditional ownership group but
there's no owner who is stuffing money
into his or her pockets by saving and
scrimping on the salary cap the packers
should always spend 100 cents on the
dollar every year because it's all
balance sheets and they're always making
money they always turn a profit we get
to see every year how they're doing they
can't say we're trying to save money
they can't say we're trying to generate
profit for the owner and it's not like
they send out dividend checks they
reinvest all of the money back into the
team but
why wouldn't you spend a hundred cents
on the dollar of every available dollar
to you under the cap and and and that's
the that's the objective in trying to
put the best team on the field so we'll
see yeah where that aspect of it goes
chris but but uh again he said he's
gonna take some time and think it
through and i don't know if he's gonna
have a press conference or just tweet
something out and tell us what he's
considered after he's thought it all
through but i think this contract issue
is going to hang around until he either
gets a new contract or he doesn't yeah
well listen the owner thinks another
thing that continually has come to my
mind
uh really over the last 36 hours or
whatever since that game ended i mean
that that is something that still
percolates about our conversation
yesterday you know first off there's
nobody there to kind of
be the guy to go no let's go for it or
no let's not go for it or
whoa we're not doing him justice and we
need to support him you know that's
where the owner can be
very helpful in in any situation he can
kind of give the gm and the owner the
guts to make those moves like hey i got
your back don't worry no problem here
you know i don't know i mean do they
save money do i guess extra money goes
to the investors all of that no no
that's not how it works so that makes
that's why no don't they don't
distribute dividends that means okay i
didn't i i the money goes into right
upgrades at lambeau field and you know
they uh you know they don't have a
traditional profit distribution
structure and that's the thing any other
owner can say well you know what i can
spend 100 of the salary cap but i don't
have to i only have to spend x percent
on a four-year basis i think it's up
into the mid-90s now but the rest of
that money i can just i can just go buy
a ferrari or you know a bunch of ferrari
with it depending upon the amount of
money that's made by a team so that's
one of the things well that
distinguishes green bay from other
franchises gotcha okay i thought that's
what you meant i just i needed you to
clarify that for me there because i am
not johnny business deal by any sense of
the imagination but uh i am johnny
football and one thing i know about
football is you know still i come back
to
last year's draft the no owner as we sit
here and talk about everything still and
it bothers me yes because they you know
they lost and everybody's blaming rogers
but just the the way that went down with
jordan love and all of that and yeah
there was corners and receivers and
defense alignment on the board
everything that would have helped out in
sunday's football game all right and and
then you know just the thought of the
quarterback thing too that that bothers
me it bothers me the the jordan love
we're gonna draft for the future when we
got one of the two or three best
quarterbacks in the game right now and
we're in the super bowl window
is such a disservice to all green bay
fans and aaron rodgers that it's just
and it's such an outdated thought it's
not in 1987 anymore green bay
we don't need the quarterback to sit on
the bench for four years okay well we're
seeing rookie quarterbacks come in the
league and be
as good as the stars right off the bat
like as good as the top quarterbacks
right in the conversation we you and i
watched joe burrow and justin herbert
this year the whole year we were like
whoa i think they might be one of the 10
best quarterbacks in the sport ever
since we saw them play sitting on what
what's it doing so i'm so frustrated
with all of it and um that that just you
know bothers me how to get that off my
chest and let me tie
it back to the point that you're making
because people are going to say well if
there's one owner it's not like the
owner tells the team who to draft they
don't meddle look folks they do meddle
they just try to make it look like they
don't meddle that you're not going if if
there is an owner if there's a jerry
jones in green bay trust me they're not
going to take jordan love and trade up
to take jordan love without running it
by the owner and making sure that the
owner is okay with it that's how it
works the owners for the most part
unlike jerry jones who made himself the
gm when he bought the team the owners
for the most part want to stay behind
the curtain and they don't want to be
perceived as as as interfering right
with the process but you're not going to
make a move like that without running it
by the owner
and and i can't think of many owners
that would say hey that's a pretty good
idea let's go ahead and do it so uh that
that's the background to where we now
are and that's that's what's driving
this speculation as sparked by the
comment made by aaron rodgers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports